[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de la grande interview à
la rentrée judiciaire de septembre 2020
a été marquée par l'ouverture du procès
des attentats de charlie hebdo un procès
pour se souvenir et comprendre
comprendre comment les frères kwasi et
coulibaly ont perpétré tant d'horreurs
et ce ne sont pas les seuls à avoir semé
le chaos sur le territoire français
alors qui sont ils
comment leur idéologie se propage-t-elle
qu'est ce qu'il révèle de l'état de
notre société bien les profils de ces
terroristes notre invité les connais
bien n'aura lakehal a été la première
femme à intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la pro de la police française nora
lakehal bonjour un grand merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
alors vous publiez agent d'élite le
récit inspirant d'une enfant de barbès
et aux éditions max milo alors pour
commencer pendant des années votre
travail a consisté à rester dans l'ombre
à vous cacher à vous transformer à
passer incognito
alors pourquoi aujourd'hui vous
choisissez de rompre cet anonymat cet
anonymat qui était votre meilleur allié
finalement pendant tant d'années
tout à fait mais en fait il a fallu
rompre avec cet anonymat pour pouvoir
raconter expliquer ce qui se passe
réellement sur le terrain
et comment les choses sont complexes on
cherche souvent à simplifier alors qu'
il faut avoir beaucoup de nuances pour
pouvoir parler de 7,2
de cette thématique là donc ce qui s'est
passé c'est que il ya quelques temps
j'étais en filatures et surveillances
sur une opération antiterroriste
donc nous étions avec mon collègue en
train d'attendre que l'objectif sorte
pour pouvoir le suivre
nous étions harnachés de nos habits donc
pour rien passer incognito nos armes on
était vraiment focus sur notre objectif
et comme vous l'imaginez de temps à
autre on est obligé d'attendre vraiment
la filature la surveillance nécessite
beaucoup de temps donc il faut être
patient nous étions sur un point fixe et
gens nous attendons nous écoutons la
radio la radio comme tout le monde le
fait et j'entends quelqu'un sur un
plateau qui dit tranquillement que en
fait
l'islam n'est pas soluble dans la
république les musulmans donc ne sont
pas solubles dans la république
et là on s'est regardés avec mon
collègue qui lui aussi est musulman et
on s'est dit maintenant mais est un
problème là c'est pas possible soit pas
dire des choses pareilles là on est en
train de parler de nous parce que nora
lakers pour ça que oui voilà parce que
effectivement voilà comment vous vous
définissez une femme française policière
un esprit libre
une musulmane mais aussi une boxeuse qui
a fait des études de sites de
philosophie vous écrivez je suis celle
qui mangent du saucisson halal en buvant
un bon verre de vin alors ce sont
finalement toutes ses facettes de votre
personnalité qui vous ont permis ce
parcours hors du commun tout à fait tout
à fait en fait je ne me suis pas je ne
me suis jamais résigné à une identité
qu'on décret très con qu'on m'a figerait
comme ça voilà je suis une femme je suis
d'origine maghrébine
je suis française républicaine musulmane
et j'aime le bon vin donc voilà forme
accepté avec tout ce que je suis et je
mange hallal aussi voilà c'est voilà
c'est la france d'aujourd'hui aussi
alors justement quel est votre état
d'esprit quand votre mission première
est celle de traquer ces terroristes on
le sait les gens très dangereux
qu'est ce que vous avez appris de ces
profils qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire qu'est ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion
écoutez avec toutes ces années que j'ai
passées donc c'est quasiment 20 ans ce
que je constate c'est que le profil via
toujours de la misère sociale
voilà c'est la misère sociale qui
commence
qui est le début du parcours ce sont des
enfants ce qu'ils sont plutôt
malheureuse pas favorisé avec des
violences violences intrafamiliales
humiliation de l'intérieur m'a aussi de
l'extérieur plus de l'ignorance c'est à
dire que à un moment ce sont des
personnes qui n'ont eu ni la chance
d'avoir des parents qui sont à la
hauteur de leurs attentes
et qui passe aussi à côté de l'éducation
nationale parce que vous nous racontez
effectivement c'est dans le titre de
votre livre c'est l'itinéraire d'une
enfant de barbès barbès on le connaît
c'est un quartier populaire vous avez
grandi aussi autour de ces jeunes qui à
un moment ont basculé la bascule elle se
fait comment tout à fait c'est tout à
fait le propos de mon écrit d'ailleurs
vous savez moi j'ai donc grandi à barbès
et en fait je me suis rendu compte que
finalement j'étais dans un lycée dans le
quartier où a grandi les kouachi et je
me suis dit mais en fait on était
quasiment du même quartier
on avait quasiment le même début plus ou
moins chaotique dans la vie bon j'ai eu
une enfance un peu difficile beaucoup de
violence
qu'est ce qui fait que à un moment et
bat nos chemins se séparent et quelqu'un
choisit de devenir terroriste est
quelqu'un je faisais devenir de
travailler dans l'antiterrorisme et
jetteront en écrivant ce livre je me
suis dit mais voilà ça si je peux
apporter quelque chose sur cette
réflexion là eh bien il faut y aller il
faut se lancer
et c'est exactement pour ça que je les
fais vous parliez de pouvoir répondre à
votre question
allez-y vous en prie oui pourrait vendre
pour répondre à votre question
voilà ce que j'ai observé c'est que
généralement on s'occupe toujours des
personnes qui ont loupé laurent le
rendez-vous avec la république et qui
sont devenus ou des délinquants ou des
terroristes
voilà mais on s'occupe jamais des gens
comme moi sachant qu'on est tout de même
probablement sept à huit millions en
france des gens qui en fait ce sont
comment dire conforme et ont été
biberonné par la république et sont des
français sans problème et cet apport que
je me permets humblement de donner
aujourd'hui c'est voilà occupez-vous un
peu aussi des gens comme moi qui n'ont
pas qu'ils ont entre guillemets réussi
et voyez quels sont les différences et
je pense que c'est ici qu'on va trouver
plusieurs solutions pour en termes de
prévention de la radicalisation
parce que ce qui est étonnant c'est
quand on vous lit on a vraiment le
sentiment à aucun moment et pourtant
vous avez des occasions à vous l'écrivez
dans le livre de basculer de l'autre
côté et on a vraiment ce sentiment là
que c'est pas possible pour vous vous
l'expliqué pas clairement je vous pose
la question aujourd'hui pourquoi vous
vous n'avez pas basculé et bien écouter
parce que moi j'ai eu beaucoup de chance
dans le sens où j'ai eu une femme qui
s'est occupée de moi lorsque j'étais
dans la misère parce qu'on peut parler
réellement de misère il n'y a pas de
problème avec ça
j'ai grandi dans une certaine aussi
ignorance une certaine voilà une
atmosphère qui n'était pas propice à
s'épanouir intellectuellement et en fait
j'ai une voisine
qui à marc péré m'a regardée et qui
s'est intéressé à moi et ça montre aussi
qu'il faut ouvrir les yeux et s'occuper
de ce qui se passe autour de soi c'est à
dire qu'on ne doit pas tout attendre de
la société il faut se regarder un peu ce
qui se passe à côté de chez nous nos
voisins ce qui se passe il ya de la
douleur qui a autour de nuit de nous il
faut vraiment essayer de tendre la main
aux autres et donc c'est tout d'abord
grâce à cette femme qui donc m'a donné
des livres m'a donné des livres parce
qu'il faut savoir que j'ai grandi dans
un endroit où il y avait pas de livres
à part le télé 7 jours et à travers ses
livres j'ai commencé à découvrir le
monde et ça pour moi ça a été la
première le premier outil de
compréhension du monde et de l'autre et
c'est là où je me suis dit peut-être que
je vaux quelque chose si cette femme
s'intéresse à moi
il y a eu la philosophie aussi ou fait
des études de philosophie avant d'entrer
dans la police là aussi ce moment là la
faculté ça a permis de vous construire
tout à fait tout à fait faut savoir que
mes parents ne voulaient absolument pas
que je fasse des études et encore moins
des études de philosophie qui pour eux
c'était une perte de temps
sèche et donc
je me suis entêtée je les fais et là
j'ai découvert des auteurs exceptionnel
dont emmanuel kant qui dans sa
philosophie morale m'a beaucoup inspiré
parce qu'en fait je l'ignorais mais au
fond de moi j'étais un petit peu
qu'ancienne c'est à dire que il a le
sens de la responsabilité et le sens de
l'action c'est à dire qu'à ça à chaque
fois que l'on agit on entraîne avec soi
l'humanité donc voilà on est on a de la
responsabilité
voilà on n'est pas juste spectateurs de
ce qui se passe autour de nous devant
nous alors de la philosophie ensuite à
la police c'est vrai que ça peut
paraître étonnant mais c'est une
rencontre avec un policier finalement
qui vous décide tout à fait tout à fait
donc pendant mes études de philosophie
j'avais besoin un peu aussi de
m'extérioriser un peu c'était assez
compliqué pour moi
et donc j'ai choisi de pratiquer un peu
par atavisme puisque mes grands parents
mes parents ont pratiqué la boxe je me
suis inscrite à un club de boxe donc sur
le 19e arrondissement
avec évidemment les mêmes profils que
moi en tant que sportif c'est on s'était
tous des jeunes des quartiers et on a eu
la chance en fait d'être entraînée par
un homme exceptionnel auquel je pense
très souvent qu'ils étaient donc
fonctionnaires de police qui était
capitaine dans un service prestigieux de
la police judiciaire parisienne
quand vous faites ce choix est ce que
vous avez le sentiment d'être jugé est
ce que votre entourage vous comprends
vos amis notamment vos amis avec qui
vous avez grandi
comment est-ce qu'il réagisse à cette à
cette annonce
écoutez j'ai été un peu surprise en fait
parce que les avis étaient complètement
d'hiver c'est à dire que bon j'ai eu ma
propre famille bien évidemment qui dit
bon là on peut plus rien faire pour elle
c'est à dire voilà elle choisi un métier
d'homme avec ait des hommes me
l'apprendre
isc donc mon père et ma mère n'était pas
très content mon frère lui n'appréciez
pas trop la police donc il ne m'a pas
parlé pendant un petit moment
considérant que la police s'était des
brutes violente voilà et et j'étais
beaucoup beaucoup surprise par certains
copains de fac qui en fait ou carrément
coupé les ponts en considérant qu'en
fait j'avais basculer du camp ennemi et
qu'à partir de là je n'étais plus
fréquentable alors on va revenir tout à
l'heure sur le coeur de votre métier
mais peut-être avant on voit souvent
dans l'actualité la haine d'une certaine
jeunesse contre la police qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez leur dire aujourd'hui je
leur dis que déjà il ne faut pas
essentialiser c'est à dire que je
comprends qu'il puisse avoir de la
révolte de la colère face à des choses
que l'on voit nous mêmes en tant que
policier on trouve cela insupportable
toute cette violence est inadmissible et
on la condamne comme en revanche il ne
faut pas oublier que pour vivre dans un
état un état de droit et en paix on a
besoin d'une police sinon ce serait
l'anarchie
donc c'est pour ça que je parle aussi
dans mon livre de la police urbaine de
proximité car je trouve que cette
manière de pacifier les rapports entre
la jeunesse et la police et
je suis contente de voir que il ya des
petits frémissements qui voudrait un peu
réintroduire ce type de rapport entre le
citoyen et le policier alors vous faites
vos années de policière finalement deux
fonctionnaires de police au sein d'un
commissariat et puis vous choisissez
l'antiterrorisme pourquoi vous accepté
cette mission en quelques mots écoutez
c'était tellement magique
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre je pense que déjà tout citoyen
après le 11-septembre avait envie de
faire quelque chose pour comment dire
pour les droits de l'homme pour des
hautes valeurs morales et quand on vient
vous voir et qu'on vous dit écoutez vous
avez de la première femme qui va rente
qui allait rentrer dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé et
pendant des années le terrorisme sera au
coeur de votre mission on va se plonger
justement dans cette mission mais tout
d'abord on fait une petite pause on vous
retrouve tout de suite n'aura la cale
[Musique]
nora lakehal et donc l'invité de la
grand nintendo view où elle publie agent
d'élite le récit inspirant d'une enfant
de barbès aux éditions max milo alors on
vient de comprendre un petit peu votre
parcours
maintenant je vous propose de nous
plonger avec vous au coeur de votre
mission à la fin de votre livre vous
écrivez une lettre à l'un des prêcheurs
salafistes que vous avez suivi grâce à
votre travail en équipe
on apprend qu'il a été arrêté par la
suite on tremble il vous a même
découvert vous avez en dire un mot
et puis il vous a parlé et vous écrivez
en vous adressant à lui à la fin de
votre livre je ne te sous-estiment
nullement pourquoi parce que nous avons
tendance
dans une sorte d'inconscient collectif à
sous-estimer ces gens là c'est à dire
que en fait on pense qu'ils sont soumis
et se soumettent un par conviction un
bien évidemment à une certaine idéologie
violente mais on pense qu'il n'ya pas
l'intelligence derrière et moi ce qui
m'a beaucoup impressionné c'est
l'intelligence l'intelligence de cet
homme
photo même savoir que c'est que c'est
quelqu'un qui s'instruit comme je
l'expliquais il écoute france culture
donc etc on ça rentre pas dans les cases
qu'on veut bien donner
d'habitude comme ça sur la place
publique et
et c'est pour ça que
j'étais vraiment très impressionné par
ce personnage
des hommes et des femmes finalement qui
connaissent parfaitement la société dans
laquelle il évolue il utilise parfois
les codes vous raconter même que ils
vont parfois à la rencontre de
prostituées tout à fait ça aussi ça a
été aussi un choc pour moi c'est
peut-être un peu de naïveté mais je ne
pensais pas que on pouvait être aussi
malhonnête ce que ça c'est à dire qu on
a suivi quelqu'un qui avaient tous les
stigmates du salafistes qui avait la
barbe la tenue les chaussettes blanches
les baskets donc on se dit bon voilà
c'est tout de même un rigoriste on
voyait bien qu'il était assez durs dans
sa famille assez sévère avec ses enfants
et tout ça et puis ben monsieur
finalement allé voir des prostituées
et alors ce qui est quand même assez
incroyable c'est à dire qu'il va pas
dépouiller les prostituées pour la cause
mais il va d'abord faire son affaire
avec les prostituées et ensuite les
dépouiller pour la cause ce qui est tout
de même assez incroyable vous en
conviendrez donc vous écrivez aussi
cette hypocrisie sécher gens là est ce
que ce sont des groupes des petits
groupes isolés qui travaille entre eux
qui montrent leur petite opération entre
eux ou alors est ce que ce sont des
groupes qui dépendraient qui dépendent
de structure un peu plus importante est
ce qu'il y a finalement des grosses
structures autour de leurs actions ça
dépend en fait y'a pas de règle sur
chaque cas les choses peuvent être
totalement différente
donc il peut y avoir des structures bien
organisée mais aussi le lambda qui va
commencer à essayer de en fait de vider
les cerveaux et c'est pour ça c'est tout
l'objet de mon livre se base là dessus
aussi
c'est à dire qu' il faut que nous
reprenions la place dans le cerveau des
enfants et de la jeunesse
on ne doit pas laisser la place aux
rigoristes avec leurs livres qui sont
quasiment gratuits dans les librairies
savez pour 2,3 euros
ben vous avez une version de l'islam qui
est totalement vidée de tout sens
vous avez juste une sorte de catalogue
de la redoute avec oui non oui non et
c'est à partir de là qu'on peut après
inculquer d'autres choses beaucoup plus
graves
donc c'est vraiment notre travail à nous
en termes de prévention de la
radicalisation c'est à nous de faire en
sorte que ces jeunes ne laisse pas la
place à ce vide intellectuel et pour l'
horreur à la nature a horreur du vide
donc pour ne pas laisser la place il
faut que la culture
il faut que les livres envahissent ses
esprits parce que ce qui est étonnant
c'est qu'à maman ce prêcheur salafistes
il vient vers vous ils vous à des
tranchées pour reprendre un code
policiers il vous a reconnu il sait que
vous le suivez depuis maintenant
plusieurs jours plusieurs mois
pour autant il va pas ni vous tuer ni
vous envoyer
ni vous dégagez en revanche ils essayent
de vous parler ils essayent de vous
retourner ce qui est assez étonnant
finalement oui tout à fait alors bien
évidemment j'ai eues on peut dire
clairement la peur de ma vie et je me
suis posé la question je me suis dit moi
j'étais prête bon je me suis bon ça
c'est fini pour moi est ce que je peux
en découdre ou pas ça va être très
compliqué parce que je suis seul
si je mes collègues sont un peu plus
éloignés est-ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est en fait
lui a donné le là tout de suite c'est
lui qui a donné le ton de l'intervention
et il est venu me parler comme ça en
faisant oeuvre de prosélytisme il m'a
parlé avec une telle douceur
on dirait vraiment un grand père qui
vient dire à sa petite fille écoute
maintenant il faut arrêter les bêtises
tu te trompes il faut aller dans le
droit chemin
donc j'étais très impressionné et il m'a
vraiment eu
il va déclencher un mois en mois
énormément de surprises et
d'interrogations et puis par la suite
j'ai appris que c'était quelqu'un quand
même qui a fait oeuvre de prosélytisme
sur des personnes qui sont quand même
qu'ils ont quand même passer à l'acte ce
qui veut dire que c'est tout de même un
spécialiste
ces profils que vous avez traquer que
vous avez permis d'arrêter
est ce qu'ils peuvent se des radicalités
selon vous ou c'est impossible notamment
avec les passages en prison
écoutez c'est très compliqué parce que
une fois de plus on peut pas
essentialiser chaque cas est particulier
on peut pas dire bah voilà avec cette
personne là enfin avec tout les meutes
des personnes on va agir de la même
manière c'est pas possible
donc il veut ferait beaucoup de temps
beaucoup de formations beaucoup de temps
avec un suivi très complexe je ne sais
pas si actuellement on en est capable ne
serait ce que par les moyens
en revanche je pense qu'il faut miser du
coup sur la prévention parce que la
prévention est bien tout le monde peut
en faire finalement voilà juste en
s'occupant de l'autre et en
développement un certain altruisme et ça
passe par repérer les personnes qui sont
des grandes difficultés la jeunesse en
particulier et qui souffrent
d'inégalités sociales
et ça commence par dire bonjour à son
voisin de palier finalement c'est ce que
vous nous dites aussi exactement tout à
fait se renseigner savoir que si elles
des cris d'enfants le soir ne pas dire
oh bah non c'est pas grave ça va
s'arrêter
essayer de se demander s'il n'ya pas
maltraitance ce sont des petites choses
qui ont l'air quand on écoute comme ça
du malheur mais quel est le rapport avec
la réducation mais c'est le rapport avec
la radicalisation
il faut préserver nos jeunes c'est la
jeunesse les jeunes de maintenant vont
être les adultes de demain et je ne
voudrais pas que dans les futurs l
adulte nous retrouvions le même profil
c'est à dire des gens qui par ces
difficultés vont s'orienter vers la
délinquance ou par ces difficultés vont
s'orienter vers le l'islamisme radical
je le disais au début de l'émission le
procès des attentats de charlie hebdo a
donc débuté dès début septembre
qu'est ce que vous en attendez vous
écoutez donc comme vous le savez je suis
encore en fonction au ministère de
l'intérieur donc par conséquent mon
devoir de réserve imposé à ne pas
commenter une affaire qui en cours
simplement je suis comme tout le monde
c'est à dire que j'ai été blessé dans ma
chair lorsque les attentats sont arrivés
et que à chaque fois que j'en entends
reparler que j'écoute des les auditions
et ben ça mais je suis vraiment
bouleversé bouleversé concernant la
traque des islamistes radicaux on en met
ou aujourd'hui de quelle menace par le
ton très précisément à écouter pour tout
ce qui est précis ça aussi ça relève de
devoir de réserve donc on peut pas en
faire état une chose est sûre c'est que
et là je le dis sans flagornerie
nous avons je peux en attester un des
services antiterroristes le plus
efficace
je pense en europe et j'étais un peu
chauvine mais aussi dans le monde
sincèrement les collègues sont des gens
qui sont passionnés qui s'investissent
qui donnent toute leur vie pour servir
l'état et la république
et sincèrement on peut en être très fier
parce que vous dites donner toute leur
vie c'est vrai que vous racontez aussi
et c'est intéressant que vous partez
parfois plusieurs semaines loin de chez
vous à dormir dans des chambres on ne
sait où à suivre finalement la vie de ce
que vous traquez oui tout à fait c'est
totalement éprouvant faut savoir que
dans ces périodes là
moi j'ai perdu toute vie sociale puisque
on est tout le temps requis on a
toujours notre portable de services à
côté de nous on peut commencer un dîner
avec des amis puis finalement ben voilà
excusez nous on part et puis on nous
demande quand est-ce qu'on doit revenir
bon je sais pas peut-être dans quatre
cinq jours et en plus avec le secret
défense mais évidemment on ne peut pas
dire où on va est ce que l'on fait et
c'est vraiment usant usant donc c'est
pour ça que quand je dis que les
collègues sacrifient leur vie ils
donnent leur vie à ce métier ce n'est
pas peu dire
vous avez beaucoup de collègues engagés
aujourd'hui sur le terrain est ce que il
y a une vraie menace elle est importante
les français doivent savoir
qu'aujourd'hui la menace terroriste est
là importante
ou alors bien finalement elle s'est un
peu estompée par rapport aux dernières
années
écoutez face à une idéologie pareil il
faut toujours rester vigilant
donc les collègues sont toujours sur le
qui vive et font de l'excellent travail
donc voilà je ce que je souhaite c'est
qu'il se préserve le plus possible aussi
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un métier
qui est très difficile et qu'on n'est
jamais à l'abri de réactions qu'ils
soient hyper violente de la part de ces
fous furieux
qu'est ce qui a changé depuis les
attentats vous parliez des attentats de
des world trade center des tours à new
york
qu'est ce qui a changé depuis dans la
feu dans la lutte contre le terrorisme
pour la police est ce que ça a beaucoup
évolué le
travail de policier at il beaucoup
évolué depuis tous ces attentats même
sur le territoire français bien sûr bien
sûr il ya eu beaucoup de de recadrage on
évolue de façon la matière
d'antiterrorisme c'est comment dire
c'est toujours évolutif ça évolue tout
le temps voilà on doit être toujours
attentif à ce qui se passe ils sont les
gens qui sont les terroristes sont très
aguerris et veut toujours devancé les
policiers donc donc du coup on est
toujours obligé de très attentifs et
d'augmenter les moyens et pour être non
seulement être au niveau et les devants
c est effectivement depuis les derniers
attentats il ya une évolution
considérable et on peut que apprécié
être fier de cela le politique vous
entends sur ces questions vous donne
suffisamment de moyens pour faire votre
travail correctement
oui oui tout à fait franchement bon
après on est comme dans toutes les
branches dans tous les métiers du monde
on a tous on veut toujours avoir plus de
moyens mais effectivement moi de ma
petite place d'agents
de l'état sincèrement c'est remarquable
j'ai pu voir le en fait j'ai la chance
d'avoir vu l'évolution sur les vingt ans
puisque j'ai toujours été sur cette
thématique là effectivement c'est
vraiment on peut que se féliciter des
avancées et après ces attentats est ce
que vous avez observé des jeunes
français qui ont voulu s'engager dans la
police nationale justement pour défendre
leur drapeau est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous avez constaté
oui beaucoup beaucoup après les
attentats de charlie hebdo de l'hyper
cacher il ya eu beaucoup il ya eu une
sorte de réveil national réveil
républicain et
et on ne peut que s'en réjouir bien
évidemment mais il est vrai que de
toutes les façons que l'on soit dans le
travail dans l'anti terrorisme ou que
les collègues soient affectés sur la
voie publique
tous ces métiers là sont vont vers le
même vers le même but c'est à dire
servir la république et prendre des
risques pour servir la république
donc on ne peut que féliciter toutes ces
personnes qui s'engagent et qui continue
à s'engager régulièrement
alors pour conclure aujourd'hui c'est
fini pour vous les filatures pendant
toutes ces années de traque
qu'est ce que vous avez appris sur vous
même quel message pour conclure vous
souhaiteriez partager aujourd'hui
écoutés sur moi même c'est peut-être pas
sur un plateau tv que je vais le je vais
le dévoiler moi en tous les cas j'ai
pris conscience en fait que rien ne
pourra se résoudre réellement dans tous
ces problématiques
si on ne résout pas on ne se penche pas
sur les inégalités sociales
voilà ça c'est vraiment le maître mot
tant qu'on s'occupera pas de notre
jeunesse
tant qu'on ne rapportera pas l'égalité
sur l'éducation
les ducs et les légalité sur les
transports et des gens qui sont vraiment
quand même qu'ils vivent à côté de la
république
et tant qu'on ne s'occupera pas deux
ça va être compliqué et aujourd'hui vous
êtes toujours en poste dans la police
nationale c'est quoi votre quotidien
mon quotidien c'est de l'administration
puisque je fais dans l'administration
centrale et bien écoutez c'est encore
une nouvelle forme une une nouvel angle
travaille sur des valable sur une
thématique complètement différente
puisque c'est administratif mais écoutez
il faut savoir s'arrêter à un moment
voilà je laisse la place maintenant
justement aux jeunes dont on parlait
pour faire le travail et reprendre le
flambeau
en tout cas un grand merci n'aura
lakehal d'avoir accepté notre invitation
je rappelle que vous publiez agent
d'élite le récit inspirant d'une enfant
de barbès c'est aux éditions max milo
cette émission est à revoir sur notre
site internet
rt france point tv à écouter également
en podcast merci pour votre fidélité à
bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]